ALAN SEALES: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I'm Alan with the Talks
at Google program here.
The show itself, "Tail!
Spin!" is the truth
laid hysterically
bare in a wild, inventive
new comedy drawn-- actually
verbatim-- from
the leaked emails,
raunchy texts, tell-tale tweets,
that brought down politicians
Anthony "I Was Hacked" Weiner,
Mark "Appalachian Trail"
Sanford, Larry "Wide Stance"
Craig, and Mark "Underage Page"
Foley.
So as they say,
"Politics is dirty.
But politicians are dirtier."
And now, performing for us
and introducing the show,
please welcome the cast
and the writer from "Tail!
Spin!"
[APPLAUSE]
MARIO CORREA: I really
thank you so much.
I'm Mario Correa.
I'm the writer of "Tail!
Spin!".
Although "writer" is sort
of a fuzzy term in our show.
Because everything you'll
hear today was actually
said by the person in question.
So it's a verbatim
recreation, our show
is, of four, real-life political
sex scandals as Alan mentioned.
I want to start off, actually,
by thanking Alan for having us
here today.
Jeremy [? Susphin, ?]
my friends at Google are
who actually got us
in touch with Alan.
So this is all because
of Jeremy and Alan too.
So thank you, guys, very much.
In our show, you'll see these
verbatim scandals played out
on stage.
And the actors, that
you'll have here today,
play a bunch of different
characters in our show.
So they take on all kinds
of different personas.
We have a projection
screen on our show,
usually, when you see it
down at the Lynn Redgrave
Theater in NoHo.
And it tells you
who is playing what.
Because they are constantly
switching characters.
But today, I'm going to
tell you who these guys are
and which characters
they're playing.
We're going to do the Anthony
Weiner scandal for you.
AUDIENCE: Whew!
MARIO CORREA: When
you come see our show,
it's a longer scandal.
Because as you
remember, Weiner kind of
kept going, and
going, and going.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: We're
going to give you
just the first part of that,
a little teaser to get you
guys downtown.
So let me start by tell
you guys who our cast is,
introducing them, and telling
you who they're going to play.
So we start with Rachel Dratch
who-- I think many of guys
know-- who is going to
start by playing-- whew!
[APPLAUSE]
MARIO CORREA: Rachel
is going to start
by playing a stripper,
called Ginger Lee,
that Anthony Wiener used
to have conversations
with on Twitter and DM.
Then she's going to switch
into a blackjack dealer,
from Las Vegas, named Lisa.
And then, eventually,
into a Texas single mom
named Megan, who all
of whom were involved
with Anthony Weiner in
one way or the other.
Tom Galantich is going
to start by being
a DJ, who questions
one of these women,
and eventually will become
Wolf Blitzer of CNN--
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: --who
will, of course,
question Anthony Weiner himself.
Then we've got
Arnie Burton who's
going to start by being
Luke Russert, young Luke
Russert, who also
questioned Anthony Weiner,
and will turn into
Gloria Allred.
She's the lawyer who, basically,
every scandalmonger person
gets involved with
at some point.
And, finally, Sean Dugan
will play Sean Hannity,
from Fox, who was
always fascinated
with any sexual misdeed
by our politicians.
And then, last but
not least, Nate Smith
is the one, the
only Anthony Weiner.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: So with
that, here's "Tail!
Spin!"
[APPLAUSE]
[GAVEL POUNDING]
[PHONE VIBRATING]
SEAN DUGAN: The gentleman
from New York is recognized.
[GAVEL POUNDING]
NATE SMITH: You
know, I think it's
time for us to take
a little review.
And also offer people
listening kind of viewer's
guide of what they've
heard and what
they're likely to
hear coming forward.
For those people
at home, playing
that now popular
drinking game of you
take a shot whenever Republicans
say something that's not true.
Please assign a
designated driver.
Nyeah?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: Nyeah?
Designated driver?
It's going to be
a long afternoon.
RACHEL DRATCH: I've made
looking at pics of me easier.
You're welcome.
[GIGGLES] Hey, I am
not a stripper, OK?
I'm a person that
strips sometimes.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH:
Stop slut-shaming.
OK.
Fuck you.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: Going
rouge over here.
Starting to Twitter
without telling my minders.
But what if nobody hears me?
Did it happen?
[BIRD TWEETING]
NATE SMITH: I have a follower.
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, I'm sorry.
I can't hear you over the
sound of my awesome blond hair.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: Clearly,
the Jew fro is working.
Nearly 10,000 followers.
If I hit that, I'll
post my bar mitzvah pic.
#don'tworry No bris pics at 20K.
Nhnh.
[BIRD TWEETING]
NATE SMITH: Bris pics.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: I will be
at the Oval Office, a strip
club in Green Bay,
Wisconsin, this weekend.
Please ignore the
irony of me stripping
anywhere with a
government-sounding name.
[CHUCKLES] Stripper
poles for all.
No?
OK.
I don't even know what I meant.
NATE SMITH: Thanks so
much for following me.
Would you like me to follow you?
Use [? #Weineryes ?]
[BIRD TWEETING]
[PHONE VIBRATING]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH:
Hey, you know it's
a good day when you wake
up to a DM from @RepWeiner.
What can I say?
I'm a fan girl, ya'll.
A DM from him is like
a DM from Buddha.
[BIRD TWEETING]
NATE SMITH: Let's get
this party started.
[BIRD TWEETING]
TOM GALANTICH: Her name is Lisa.
So this all started
back in August of 2010
when you contacted him?
RACHEL DRATCH: I am looking
for the wonderful Anthony
Weiner, who I feel in
love with for yelling
at those damn Repubs
the other day.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
TOM GALANTICH: And how did
this transcript, this Facebook
transcript, of
your conversations
with Congressman
Weiner get released.
RACHEL DRATCH: Your
friend requests are full.
You must friend me.
You are awesome.
NATE SMITH: Thank you, Lisa.
Glad you have my back.
RACHEL DRATCH: Ha, ha.
It is you.
You are the coolest
Dem on the planet.
When are you coming to Vegas to
help me beat up the right wing
crazies?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
TOM GALANTICH: And then, this
sort of online flirtation?
NATE SMITH: I'm ready
for a Vegas trip.
Truth telling during the day.
Got a night planned for us?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: Ha, ha.
That is a very loaded questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: I've got all
kinds of night plans for us.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Make me an
offer I can't refuse.
RACHEL DRATCH: First, we
watch back-to-back episodes
of "The Daily Show"
and "Colbert Report".
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: Then,
when we're really hot,
we go to the bookstore and
cover all the Glenn Beck books
with copies of "The
Audacity of Hope."
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: Or if
that's not your thing,
we could just get really drunk
and have mad passionate sex.
[MESSENGER ALERTS]
NATE SMITH: Why choose?
With me behind you, can't
we both watch "Daily Show"?
TOM GALANTICH: Uh-hoh.
So basically, you're
getting the shaft.
RACHEL DRATCH: Uh.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: You are so right.
The perfect liberal evening.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: I hear liberal
girls are very accommodating.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH:
Hey, it's all about
taking care of the little guy.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Little?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: Ouch.
You'd be surprised how big.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
[NEWS REPORT THEME MUSIC]
SEAN DUGAN: Megan
Broussard, the woman
responsible for helping to
expose the shocking truth
about Anthony Weiner.
Now, it started off
as just friendly.
Tell us how it evolved.
RACHEL DRATCH: Um, you know,
just, like, chatting every day,
like, hey, how's it going?
Good morning, good evening.
That sort of thing.
SEAN DUGAN: OK.
So when, all of a sudden, the
conversations as we know it,
then, became pretty
sexual in nature from him.
NATE SMITH: My
tights really itch.
I need a distraction.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: What's up, baby?
NATE SMITH: [CHUCKLES] Whoa.
Looks like I am.
Want to ride it?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: And you
thought that was strange.
That was bizarre.
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah, I
decided this is crazy nuts.
SEAN DUGAN: And it was.
RACHEL DRATCH: Hard for me?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: Very
explicit at times?
RACHEL DRATCH: Mm,
sometimes, a little bit.
NATE SMITH: You
like me big and fat?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: Only your cock.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: Right.
And then, all of
a sudden, photos.
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah,
maybe about five.
SEAN DUGAN: And, I
guess, the second one
was him with his cats.
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, yeah.
SEAN DUGAN: And then,
he uses the vernacular,
the sexual vernacular, for cat?
NATE SMITH: Pussy still
tight and wet for me, baby?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: And did
you take it that way?
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah, about to
get drunk and bang my friend
because you're not here.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Think of
my rock hard cock.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: Uh-huh.
NATE SMITH: Practice
saying, "God, Anthony, I'm
coming again."
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: I
will do that for you.
Waiting it out
until you get here
to fuck the shit out of me.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: While I
have your attention,
please get your friends to
follow me. #Jewfropickincluded.
[CHUCKLES]
[BIRD TWEETING]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: Did you think?
RACHEL DRATCH: I
thought, OK, weird.
But--
NATE SMITH: Thinking of you
on me while I kiss your tits,
hold you down,
and take you deep.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: I'm about to bang
my friend because you're not
here.
We'll call him Anthony.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: And when he
sent you the picture of him
with his shirt off,
what'd you think of that?
RACHEL DRATCH: I just said,
Mm, I don't know about this.
NATE SMITH: I hope
he has a big cock.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: I mean, that is
kind of out there, daredevil.
SEAN DUGAN: And you
even said that to him
in some conversation.
RACHEL DRATCH: Mm-hm.
NATE SMITH: Baby, you'd
be crawling to the door
to prevent me from
fucking you silly.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: What
did you say to him?
RACHEL DRATCH: I just
said, you know, I'm
not as open as you are talking
about this sort of thing.
And he said--
NATE SMITH: I'm an open book.
Maybe too open.
RACHEL DRATCH: Nice.
I want to bang the
future mayor of NYC.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Making me hard.
NATE SMITH: I'll be here,
today, to answer questions
at 2:30 Eastern.
[BIRD TWEETING]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: You give good head?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: Yes.
And then--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: --there
is another photo--
RACHEL DRATCH: I've
been told really good.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
SEAN DUGAN: --that
is totally explicit--
NATE SMITH: Wow.
A Jewish girl that sucks cock.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Am I allowed
to tweet on Pesach?
[BIRD TWEETING]
SEAN DUGAN: --of
his private parts.
NATE SMITH: Ridiculous
bulge in my shorts now.
Want to see?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah.
Can you send of pic?
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Uh,
#HappyBdayObamaCare.
Anh.
[BIRD TWEETING]
RACHEL DRATCH: I
just thought, OK
he is going to get
hemmed up somewhere.
SEAN DUGAN: You knew
it was inevitable?
RACHEL DRATCH: I want to sit
on your cock so bad right now.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: Geez.
I'm rushing.
Let me take a quick pic.
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah.
I just knew.
[LAUGHTER]
[CAMERA CLICKING]
NATE SMITH: This thing
is ready to do damage.
[BIRD TWEETING]
[NEWS REPORT THEME MUSIC]
TOM GALANTICH: This
is the picture.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
TOM GALANTICH: I'm sure
you've seen it by now.
Is this you?
NATE SMITH: I can tell you this
that we have a firm that we've
hired. [NERVOUS CHORTLE]
I've seen it.
It's-- I've seen it.
A firm that we've hired to
get to the bottom of it.
I could tell this, that
photos can be manipulated.
Photos can be of
one thing changed
to look like something else.
[NEWS REPORT THEME MUSIC]
ARNIE BURTON : But, Congressman,
you would remember if you take
a photograph of
yourself like that.
NATE SMITH: Look, this story's
become a little bit out
of control.
ARNIE BURTON : So you
will not flat out say that
the photograph is not you?
NATE SMITH: This a prank
intended, I believe,
to make fun of me.
RACHEL DRATCH: OMG.
Are you OK?
So sorry you got hacked.
I know you'd never
have Facebook sex.
[MESSENGER ALERT]
NATE SMITH: You know, maybe
if my name was Hamburger,
this would be a picture
of something else.
Nyeah?
ARNIE BURTON : Thank you.
NATE SMITH: Hamburger?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: It's
not a federal case.
And maybe this'll turn out to be
the point of al Qaeda's sword.
ARNIE BURTON : Oh, yeah.
NATE SMITH: Nyeah?
ARNIE BURTON : Yeah.
TOM GALANTICH: We
just, we just want
to resolve this
once and for all.
I mean, well, you
would know if these
were your underpants,
for example.
NATE SMITH: I appreciate you
continuing to flash that at me.
It certainly doesn't
look familiar to me.
But I don't want to say,
with certitude, to something
that I don't know to
the certain truth.
TOM GALANTICH:
Well, have you ever
taken a picture of
yourself like this?
ARNIE BURTON : It's a fair point
for your constituents to know
if there's photographs,
of your area down there,
on your phone being
sent out to people.
NATE SMITH: You've asked
this a couple of times.
And I've tried to answer it.
TOM GALANTICH: Are you
protecting someone?
NATE SMITH: I'm protecting my
wife, who every day is waking
up to these insane
stories that are
getting so far from reality.
She doesn't deserve this.
TOM GALANTICH: Yes,
I know your wife.
She's a great lady.
You're lucky to
be married to her.
How is she handling it all?
NATE SMITH: Well, she's bemused.
ARNIE BURTON : Why
not answer that?
Is the photograph you?
NATE SMITH: Let's
make it very clear.
The implication
here is that I did
something wrong to someone else.
I was a victim of a prank.
I was a victim of a prank here.
The fact of the matter is
that that's the bottom line.
[PAPARAZZI CAMERA CLICKS]
[CROWD MUMBLING]
NATE SMITH: Thank you
very much for being
here, and good afternoon.
Last Friday night, I tweeted
a photograph of myself
that I intended to send
as a direct message,
as part of a joke, to
a woman in Seattle.
Once I realized I had posted
it to Twitter, I panicked.
I took it down.
And I said that I
had been hacked.
I, then, continued
with that story
to stick to that
story, which was
a hugely regrettable mistake.
In addition, over
the past few years,
I have engaged in several
inappropriate conversations
conducted over Twitter,
Facebook, email,
and occasionally on the phone
with women I have met online.
I am deeply regretting
what I have done.
And I am not resigning.
TOM GALANTICH: Has Gloria
Allred contacted you
yet, the attorney?
Oh, she will.
Just wait.
She always comes
out of the woodwork
over this kind of stuff.
[PAPARAZZI CAMERA CLICKS]
ARNIE BURTON : Ginger Lee has
been a [? fake-your-jams ?]
after five and a half years.
In addition to dancing,
she's currently
studying to be a
real estate agent.
RACHEL DRATCH: Hi.
ARNIE BURTON : In the past,
she's appeared in adult films.
Ms. Lee is very
interested in politics.
RACHEL DRATCH:
Surprise, bitches.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : She began to
follow Congressman Weiner
on Twitter.
At first, their conversations
were about politics.
But, sometimes, he'd try to
take it to another level,
mentioning his package.
BOTH: I have
wardrobe demands too.
I need to highlight my package.
All right, my package and
I are not going to beg.
We both see the
hazard of going down
the path of
comparative sexiness.
You aren't giving my
package due credit.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : (YELLING) Then--
NATE SMITH: [SHY MUMBLES]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : When
the scandal broke,
she was inundated with
pressing [? pareez ?].
She asked Congressman
Weiner how to handle it!
NATE SMITH: Have a
couple of iterations of,
this is silly, like
so many others.
I follow Rep.
Weiner on Twitter.
I don't know him.
And I never met him.
ARNIE BURTON : This has been a
very difficult and trying time
for Ginger!
RACHEL DRATCH: I've got
enough shit to deal with.
ARNIE BURTON : Because
of the scandal,
she's had to cancel appearances!
RACHEL DRATCH:
Without people trying
to get all up in my
zen zone to fuck it up.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : She needs to
return to work and resume her
career as a future dancer!
RACHEL DRATCH: Owners, managers,
DJs, and dancers of the United
States, please, please, for
the love of all things sacred,
put a cap on the number
of Nickelback songs played
per shift.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - NICKELBACK, "ROCKSTAR"]
[PAPARAZZI CAMERA CLICKS]
NATE SMITH: Nah.
[CROWD JEERING]
NATE SMITH: Today, I'm
announcing my resignation
from Congress so that my
colleagues can get back
to work, my neighbors can
choose a new Representative,
and most importantly, so that
my wife and I can continue
to heal from the
damage I have caused.
To repeat, most importantly,
most importantly,
so then I can continue to heal
from the damage I have caused.
I'm running for mayor!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Mario, let's
talk about the origination
of the show.
Where you wrote, "wrote" it.
MARIO CORREA: Yeah, yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I put this
in loose quotes, right?
So how did it, what's
the background?
What's the story?
How did you decide to do this?
MARIO CORREA: So I used to
be a staffer on Capitol Hill.
I worked on Capitol
Hill for a long time.
And came across some
of the politicians
that we actually
profile in our show.
SEAN DUGAN: Literally?
MARIO CORREA: Sort
of, yeah, yeah.
SEAN DUGAN: Dude.
MARIO CORREA: Mark
Foley was a Congressman
who IMed the underaged pages.
You guys may remember him.
He was the head of the Committee
on Exploited and Missing
Children.
And he was IMing
underaged pages at night.
And so I knew I wanted to
write a play, basically,
about a fictionalized
Congressman living
two lives like he did.
And I started reading the
Mark Foley transcripts
to get inspiration for
writing a play like this.
But then, I realized, when
I saw these transcripts,
that there was no way
that I could make up
the kinds of things
that these guys said
and have anyone believe it.
So I thought, Oh, OK.
Well, we should just stick
exactly to things they said.
And that was the genesis of
the idea, which expanded, then,
to the other politicians.
ALAN SEALES: Nice.
So it was there--?
Oh, well I guess, Mark is here.
MARK DOUGLAS: Hi, sorry.
ALAN SEALES: Mark--
MARK DOUGLAS: I was trying
to find you a water.
RACHEL DRATCH: Well, and
then, they brought, oh.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh. [CHUCKLES]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
we got you covered.
MARK DOUGLAS: I had a chance
to get Rachel Dratch a water.
And I took you.
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, my gosh.
You're seriously--
MARK DOUGLAS: But then--
ALAN SEALES: Fair enough.
MARK DOUGLAS: --I screwed up.
RACHEL DRATCH: [GIGGLES]
ALAN SEALES: So Mark--
MARK DOUGLAS: What'd I miss?
ALAN SEALES: Well,
I was going to--
MARK DOUGLAS: You guys
performed or something?
No, I'm just kidding.
ALAN SEALES: I was
going to introduce you.
But then, you ran away.
[? MARIO CORREA: Just ?]
let him pussies and cocks.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's OK.
I'm not that important.
Let's just get as many people on
the stage as you possibly can.
[LAUGHTER]
[? SEAN DUGAN: Quit ?]
saying those words.
ALAN SEALES: Anybody
want us to sit down here
in front, that's cool.
All right.
So what else?
Were there other scandals
that you looked at.
And you were like, oh,
this is either too bad or--
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, who
didn't make the cut?
MARIO CORREA: It's funny.
There's so many
possibilities when
you're doing sex
scandals and politicians.
It's like, the world
is your oyster, really.
I knew that wanted
Anthony Weiner.
Because it was such
a crazy, social media
bred scandal, right?
I knew that I wanted
Larry Craig, who
is played by Sean, who is in
the bathroom having, trying to
have sex in the
Minneapolis Airport.
I knew that I wanted
Mark Foley because
of the underage
component, which I thought
was a different kind of thing.
And then, we have more
of romantic scandal,
that Tom plays, which is
Governor Sanford, the guy who
went to South Carolina
to, supposedly--
well, he was the governor.
And he was, supposedly,
hiking the Appalachian Trail.
Really he was with his
mistress in Argentina.
Those are the ones that
I want to focus on.
But I considered John
Edwards, for example.
SEAN DUGAN: Ah, he
would have been great.
MARIO CORREA: There
was David Vitter.
There was, I mean, there's
all kinds of politicians.
You have no dearth of
possibilities there, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: So
what do you think,
other than the
obvious things, what
do you think that all
four of these guys
have in common that
just makes them so--?
I feel like there's something
about people who just refuse
to let go and throw
in the towel that
just is so great for comedy.
Is that-- I guess I kind
of answered the question,
didn't I?
[LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : That's
going to be easy, then.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, I want to--
MARIO CORREA: Answer is yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: All right.
Cool.
I wanted to ask some
of the actors a lot
of you have, obviously,
done sketch comedy.
Is there a different approach,
I mean, do you sort of approach
that-- I mean Rachel-- do you
approach this the same way you
would like an "SNL" sketch?
ALAN SEALES: Or Nate,
too, from "UCB".
MARK DOUGLAS: Or
Nate, of course.
Yeah
NATE SMITH: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: I mean, is
there a big difference
between this kind of
thing and a sketch?
RACHEL DRATCH: I mean, I
pretty much approach this just
like "SNL", "The Second City".
But our approach
is very sketchy.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: But then, I think
the guys, who all, they each
have kind of an arc.
So some of them have
to-- well, I mean,
you can see with Anthony Weiner.
There are moments where you
actually feel for these guys.
You actually feel bad
for them at some points,
which you might
not have expected.
So I mean, there is an
element to real acting in here
as well for sure.
But because I'm sort of
darting in and out of things,
I'm definitely more--
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
RACHEL DRATCH:
--sketchy, I guess.
MARIO CORREA: Well, yeah.
Since Rachel plays
all the women,
all the mistresses
except for Gloria Allred.
She plays all the mistresses,
all the wives, all of the--
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, it
says, "wives, tails, beards,
and Barbara Walters".
RACHEL DRATCH: Barbara
Walters at the end.
MARK DOUGLAS: Which
could be it's own play.
RACHEL DRATCH: It could be, yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: Definitely,
it's a, I mean,
that could be an awesome--
ALAN SEALES: Children's book.
RACHEL DRATCH: Well, because
some of the wives are very,
a lot of them are very
"stand by your man".
And they're just stick
by them to the end.
And then, Sanford, who's last
in our show-- Jenny Sanford
isn't like that.
And I feel like by the
time she comes around,
the audience is, they're so
psyched that somebody didn't
stand by the guy that
there's this big burst
of spontaneous applause.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: Because
I think they're just
waiting for someone
to say, like, no.
I wasn't going to
stand up there.
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Billy, you're
the show's producer there,
on the end, right?
So the show originally was at
the Fringe festival, correct?
BILLY ZAVELSON: Right.
So two years ago, 2012, I
bumped into Mario at the gym,
right here.
RACHEL DRATCH: It's
where it all happened.
BILLY ZAVELSON:
Not the Google gym.
MARIO CORREA: One of
us was working out.
And the other one
was not so much.
BILLY ZAVELSON: Everyone
was at a typewriter.
MARIO CORREA: So you
can tell which one.
[LAUGHTER]
BILLY ZAVELSON: No, I'm great.
But whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
BILLY ZAVELSON: So
he came up to me.
And he said he wrote this play.
MARIO CORREA: You're
supposed to say no.
BILLY ZAVELSON: Right, exactly.
MARIO CORREA: OK.
OK.
BILLY ZAVELSON: But
he came up to me.
And he told me that
he wrote this play.
And any time somebody
says that, usually, it's
just like, I don't
want to hear anymore.
Because, more than
likely, that play stinks.
And especially if
it's a friend, right?
You don't want to.
So he told me about it.
And it sounded, I love politics.
And, of course, I like
theater and comedy.
And it sounded great.
So I read it.
And I fell in love with it.
And he had already submitted
it to the Fringe Festival.
But he needed a producer.
And I happily joined on.
We had another partner, Marianne
Mills, who came on with us.
And we did it there.
Some of our cast was
a part of that cast.
Sean Dugan, Nate
Smith, and Rachel
were all a part of that company.
And we put it up.
And it was excellent.
It was excellent.
It was exciting.
It was right after the
most recent scandal
on that, was that one was--?
MARIO CORREA: Had been,
I think, the Weiner one
had just happened.
BILLY ZAVELSON: Weiner
MARIO CORREA: Yeah, yeah.
BILLY ZAVELSON: You're right.
And the critics loved it.
The audiences loved it.
And so then we decided to
make a commercial go of it.
And it took a long time.
It took about two years.
Then, we got it up and running
at the Lynn Redgrave Theater
downtown at Culture Project.
And we started
performances September 18.
Opened October 1.
And we're now running
through February 1.
MARIO CORREA: And during
those intervening two years,
tow of the guys ran
for office again.
And had other scandals
the second time.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: Weiner and Sanford
were like, thank God for that.
BILLY ZAVELSON: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it was
really, literally,
the gift that kept on giving.
Two days before we opened,
Larry Craig was, he was--
MARIO CORREA: He was fined.
BILLY ZAVELSON: --fined, right?
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
BILLY ZAVELSON: For
using campaign funds
to fight his legal battles
for snooping around
in the bathrooms.
And Sanford had
just posted, the day
before we started performances,
Sanford posted a 2,500 word
post, on his wall on Facebook,
basically breaking it off with
is Argentine lover.
And things are
continuing to evolve.
So as they do, we're evolving
the show, which is a headache,
but also really great too.
MARIO CORREA: Every day.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, it's funny.
Because it's almost, when
you think about the things
that they actually did to start
these things off, they're bad.
But they're not the worst
things in the world.
But it's almost just how
they handled it afterwards,
especially with Weiner.
I mean, just I feel like
I was around in the city
when, I felt like I saw
him around the city a lot.
It was almost like
he was like, yeah.
I'm doing this.
It was like a performance
piece or something.
But how did you
get that little--
ALAN SEALES: Your piece.
MARK DOUGLAS: Performance
piece, yeah. [CHUCKLES]
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: How did you get
that little "nyeah" noise?
Was that based on a real thing?
Or was that--
NATE SMITH: It's based on--
MARK DOUGLAS: Was that
on the transcription?
NATE SMITH: --his being Jewish.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: Got you.
Got you.
NATE SMITH: I don't think
he really does that.
[? MARIO CORREA: It ?]
seems so right, though.
ALAN SEALES: It does.
NATE SMITH: I
think people have--
because he doesn't
really do that.
I mean--
MARIO CORREA: I've
never asked you.
I always wondered.
But you made it work.
NATE SMITH: It's a
combination of Lenny Bruce
and SpongeBob is what it is.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: It just sort
of naturally came out.
It's not something
he does, really.
I just thought it was a nuance
that would be fun to add.
SEAN DUGAN: And yet,
it seems like everyone
thinks that he does.
Because it always gets
a laugh of recognition.
NATE SMITH: What he
does do is write really
corny humor in his tweets,
and his texts, and stuff.
And and that just was,
generally, his persona.
He was kind of
aggressively funny
in a way that wasn't
particularly funny to me.
ALAN SEALES: So
the drinking game,
and the hamburger comment--
NATE SMITH: Yeah, the
drinking, the hamburger--
ALAN SEALES: --this
is all verbatim
from something he said.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wait. even
that nickel bag line was?
NATE SMITH: Yeah.
Everything.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, my God.
MARIO CORREA: Everything
comes from something
that's really been said.
[LAUGHTER]
BILLY ZAVELSON: It's so
funny that you say that.
Because we feel like
we're banging people
over the head with this.
There's a sign,
before they walk in,
that "every single thing you
hear was tweeted, texted,
told", whatever.
We have it before every scene.
And it's so funny.
People still leave
the theater and say,
I cannot believe that that
happened or that they said
that.
[LAUGHTER]
BILLY ZAVELSON: And they did.
It's remarkable.
It's extraordinary.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, I
think some of the moments,
from remembering--
MARIO CORREA: Surprise, bitches.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: That's
what I was about to ask.
Because you're known--
RACHEL DRATCH: I don't know
that she said that then, right?
MARIO CORREA: She said it in
her blog post about something.
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah, that's
the one we took some liberties.
She really said those things.
But probably not when she was
up there with Gloria Allred,
right?
MARIO CORREA: Right, not
during the press conference.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: In
our world, yeah.
RACHEL DRATCH: I think that's
the only place we did that.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, Sean,
you're the naughty boy
speech about Bill Clinton.
SEAN DUGAN: Oh, yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: I felt
like you almost, he
said it more ridiculous
than you, actually.
You delivered it more
like a person then he.
SEAN DUGAN: I've started
zhugging it a little bit.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah.
Can we hear a
little bit of that?
SEAN DUGAN: Well, gosh.
Let's see.
Can I get into him?
Can I embody Larry
Craig right now?
Let's see.
What did he--?
Oh, yes.
The American people,
already know-- thank you,
paddle-- the American
people already
know that Bill Clinton is
a bad boy, a naughty boy.
I'm going to speak out for
the citizens of my state
who, in the majority, think
that Bill Clinton is probably
even a nasty, bad, naughty boy.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: Out of context.
SEAN DUGAN: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK DOUGLAS: OK, maybe
you didn't underplay it.
[? ARNIE BURTON : Bad. ?]
SEAN DUGAN: It's evolved
since you saw the show.
MARIO CORREA: Sure.
MARK DOUGLAS: Sure.
SEAN DUGAN: I
really just allowed
him to be the queen
that he wants to be.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: It's a
moment in the play when
I'm not doing anything.
And I just watch
Sean's bottom lip.
Because it quivers
with this subtlety
that just really
makes you laugh.
Boy.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: How much
liberty do each of you
take with the
characters in making
it an exaggeration
versus true-to-life?
RACHEL DRATCH: Well, I think
in some, well I don't know.
In some, I try to do
a real impression.
And in others, I
just do like, here's
what I think this
person would sound like.
Or here's what would be funny.
And then, others are more
sort of true to the--
TOM GALANTICH:
Yeah, I think we're
doing giant
characterizations of them.
We're doing overblown
versions, for the most part,
I think just to take
advantage of most,
as much as we can
of the material.
MARK DOUGLAS: I particularly
enjoy your sudden explosion
into tears.
TOM GALANTICH: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: That
Sanford isn't really nice.
Is there any trick to that?
TOM GALANTICH:
[CHUCKLES] I don't know.
Just being Jewish, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM GALANTICH: No.
[CHUCKLES] No, it's just fun.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, yeah.
MARIO CORREA: There's a moment
when Arnie, as Mark Foley,
jumps in as Congressman
Mark Foley in the beginning
of a scene, when Mark
Foley's the guy who
was IMing those underaged pages.
And Arnie starts the scene.
I should let you
describe what you do
and how you select the person in
the audience that you do it to.
Because that's a really--
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : Oh,
well, it starts,
the whole Mark Foley section
starts where he's addressing
the graduating, if you will,
class of the pages for that
year.
And this was the year where
the underaged page, that he
was corresponding
with, was there.
And so it takes place.
And I'm introduced.
And I'm addressing the pages.
So I thought it would be
fun every night to go out
in the audience and
fondle, use the audience
as the pages and a good
excuse to fondle an audience
member every night.
MARK DOUGLAS: Do you need one?
ARNIE BURTON : I thought
it would be fun to go out
and fondle.
Just like in the sound byte.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: Just fondle, yeah.
TOM GALANTICH: Just
so you know, there's
no warning about that
when you walk in the door.
ARNIE BURTON : Yeah.
ARNIE BURTON : And so, during
their sketches I'm looking
around, seeing who would
be best that I could fondle
and wouldn't get
pissed off, or hit me,
or try to-- so it's
dicey every night.
[LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : Some nights,
people are really into it
and play along.
And then, there's some nights, I
have just picked the wrong guy.
Because I go up.
And I like, [FONDLING NOISES].
[CHUCKLING] One night,
I got so carried away,
I started-- because
they really enjoy it.
One night, I had put my
finger in a guy's mouth.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: That's getting
your money's worth right there.
BILLY ZAVELSON: Yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, now you're
ready to play [? Head Wig, ?] I
guess.
But I was thinking about that.
I wonder if people
get a little freaked
out about Ebola
and stuff with it.
But anyway, that's just
something I was thinking of.
SEAN DUGAN: Ebola's the
least of your worries
if Arnie Burton's putting
his finger in your mouth.
[LAUGHTER]
ARNIE BURTON : [LAUGHS] Wow.
SEAN DUGAN: No, actually, no.
That was terrible.
ARNIE BURTON : I know.
SEAN DUGAN: I retract that.
ARNIE BURTON : Yes.
I'm clean.
ALAN SEALES: Quick.
Ask a question.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Uh, uh, uh.
MARK DOUGLAS: What do you got?
Well, it's funny.
As you are all actors,
it feels like the line
between politicians
and actors is
getting more and more blurry.
There's something
about, what do you
think it is that compels these
people just keep going and not
knowing when to stop
once they've sort of--
and when it's obviously
over for them?
ARNIE BURTON : A few weeks ago,
the real page that Mark Foley
corresponds with, three of those
pages came to see the show.
We were very excited.
Because it was, of all
the stars and celebrities
who have come to see the
show, that was, for me, like,
oh my God.
And we got to talk
to them afterwards.
And I was talking to
the three of them.
And they said, you know,
it's so much about--
and he was very dear.
Because he was very nervous
about seeing it and seeing
his words put up there.
MARK DOUGLAS: Did
you sit on his lap?
ARNIE BURTON : Oh,
well, you know.
MARK DOUGLAS: In the front and--
ARNIE BURTON : We
started texting.
We're seeing each other now.
MARK DOUGLAS: Next
thing you know--
ARNIE BURTON : And
we're very happy.
MARK DOUGLAS: [INAUDIBLE]
ARNIE BURTON : But
and we were talking.
He said it so much about--
because it's, especially
for him, in the
Mark Foley section,
it's hard to understand why this
17-year-old kid played along.
And he said it's so much
about power with these guys.
And from both
sides, I think they
get caught up in
their own power.
And they think they're
invincible in a way.
And they think they
can keep doing this
or, in Weiner's case, lie to
the press, and just say it.
And that's true.
And then, go on
and keep doing it.
Because I think they
feel they're above.
They're so brainwashed
with their own power.
And then, the people
beneath them, these pages,
and whoever they're dealing
with, are so awed by this power
that they get sucked into
this vortex of toxic power.
NATE SMITH: I will
say, conversely,
that we hold them to
this ethical standard
that they should be
the infallible people.
And the the Larry
Craig scandal is
one where we talked
about repeatedly.
That this is a guy who is from
a generation where you live,
if you're a gay man-- and he's
of a constituency that wouldn't
accept one of their elected
leaders being a gay man.
So he really was living a lie.
And it is--
SEAN DUGAN: Allegedly,
we don't know.
NATE SMITH: Yeah, allegedly.
He's alledge, you know.
NATE SMITH: Yeah.
So on one hand, there is
this the lure of power.
On the other hand,
there's a feeling
that we are expecting them
to be infallible people.
And it's just not a reality.
SEAN DUGAN: But that's an
interesting observation
that politicians and actors,
there's a line blurring.
Because, to me, it
also seems like you've
got an almost completely
dysfunctional government.
But then, you also have the news
media has become infotainment.
It's about ratings
rather than actually
giving the news to people.
So then, I think that you
really have to care a lot.
And I think you have
to care a lot more
than the average American voter
does about what's going on
to really get through
all the crap between so
many of these people who
are elected to fight.
And compromise has
become a dirty word.
And they grandstand
and all this stuff.
And then, the people, who
are reporting about them,
are doing the same thing.
And the--
MARIO CORREA: They all become
talk show hosts at the end
anyway.
ARNIE BURTON : Yeah.
SEAN DUGAN: Yeah.
MARIO CORREA: And they
go right from Congress
to host the show on Fox News.
So it's one in the same, really.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, we're
all interested in it.
ARNIE BURTON : --doing the show.
And then, two books,
"The Unwinding" and "This
Town" together.
And it completely soured
me on politics forever.
Just because--
MARIO CORREA: This town
is [INTERPOSING VOICES].
ARNIE BURTON : --the whole thing
has become so, it's almost like
it's become so show biz, that
you feel the politicians,
that are coming in now, and the
people that are covering them,
it's all about show biz.
And they're all in
it to be famous,
to chase that thing instead of--
MARIO CORREA: And that's why
it's easy to make a comedy out.
Because these guys really
are low-rent comedians.
So as Rachel, I think,
often points out,
she's like, "We didn't
write these jokes.
We sort of found
them and figured
out how to really make them
pop in what is a comedy."
So audiences, who come see
our show, they really laugh.
Because it's a comedy.
But these guys
actually said this.
And, by the way, it's
your government at work.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, yeah,
it reminds me of, on "SNL"--
you see that show?
You know that show?
When Tina Fey, I
remember there was
a point where she
was literally just,
I don't even think
they wrote anything.
It was, literally,
just the Sarah Palin--
[?
MARIO CORREA: Sarah
Palin, yeah. ?]
MARK DOUGLAS: --interview.
And I was waiting
for, I was like, oh.
This is the actual interview.
But it's hilarious.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
TOM GALANTICH: For me,
the large-- oh, I'm sorry.
One thing to add.
For me, the larger issue
has always been, in addition
to all of that, is
the infancy that we're
in in dealing with the type
of media that's out there now,
and with learning about
tweeting, and about Facebook
messages, and things like that.
And they're out there in
the ethernet somewhere.
But are they really retrievable?
And in this case,
a lot of them were.
And so, to me, it's about
these men and about us
as a whole learning to deal
with what you all are creating,
which is this different world
that we're living in now,
where information
is instantaneous.
MARIO CORREA: You guys got all
the DM jokes, which sometimes
audiences are like-- because
theater goers can be older.
And they're like, what's a DM?
[LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: In a way, I was
like, you guys are laughing.
MARIO CORREA: Is like the DL?
TOM GALANTICH:
So, for me, that's
the larger issue, how we deal
with that as a society, then,
going forward.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you mentioned
that the pages came
and saw your show
a little while ago.
Let's say Anthony Weiner
was coming next week.
How would that influence
how you guys did the show?
Would that change anything?
[? MARIO CORREA: Press. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: For the positive.
ARNIE BURTON : I don't know if,
I do know I was a little extra
nervous when we knew that the
pages we're going to be there
that night.
Because these people are
so outlandish in a way,
we tend to forget
that-- at least I
do-- that they're
actually real people.
And it brought it home the night
that they were there that, oh,
my God.
These are all real people,
They all said that.
Especially meeting
him afterwards.
Because he was still sweating.
He had sweat the page.
He was so sweet.
But he was really sweating
through the Foley section.
And it really brought home
that these are real people.
And, especially,
him because he got
caught up in something
that he did not
want to be caught up in.
SEAN DUGAN: Well, but
there's a difference
between the real person,
and the politician,
and the people
that were affected
by it who weren't politicians.
ARNIE BURTON : But Sean thinks,
every night in the audience,
that there's someone.
SEAN DUGAN: I was
totally convinced
that Mark Sanford
was at our show.
And I shit myself.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: So
that's the answer,
for me, is that I was
sitting right here.
And there was a guy right
there who looked exactly
like Mark Sanford, with
a woman next to him,
and no one on
either side of them.
And they were watching--
MARIO CORREA: She looked
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SEAN DUGAN: --the
show like this.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: There was
very little laughter,
during the whole show.
But during the Sanford stuff,
they found nothing funny.
They did not clap
after the show.
It was cray.
ARNIE BURTON :
But you were like,
the Koch brothers
are there today.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN DUGAN: David
Koch was over there.
ARNIE BURTON : Satan's is there.
Satan's in the third row.
SEAN DUGAN: No, it's true.
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, yeah.
You were like, Anderson
Cooper's out there.
Then I looked.
I was like, that is a poor
facsimile of Anderson Cooper.
[LAUGHTER]
BILLY ZAVELSON: To
answer your question,
I think it's likely
that that could
happen depending on
which politician.
I think it may be too
soon after Anthony's
failed mayoral campaign.
But someone like Foley,
I have connection to him
through friends,
down in Florida,
who say that he is
considering another run.
He probably would not
hate seeing this so much.
I think it's likely.
And I hope that they do come.
I mean, look.
I hope Craig comes.
NATE SMITH: I think,
ultimately, it's a comedy.
I mean, we are sort of stirring
a mock-up a little bit.
But it also is a comedy.
It's meant to be funny.
MARK DOUGLAS: And you're not
embellishing the dialogue.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NATE SMITH: Yeah.
Yeah, they're expensive.
MARIO CORREA: We do know
that Barbara Walters, who
was played by Rachel in our
show in one of the crowd
favorite moments of our
show, her hairdresser came.
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, really?
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
RACHEL DRATCH: I
didn't know this.
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
Yeah, the hairdresser came.
RACHEL DRATCH: That was
the Anderson Cooper guy?
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
RACHEL DRATCH: No.
MARIO CORREA: And we thought
that that was like the-- yeah.
RACHEL DRATCH: I
didn't know that.
MARIO CORREA: --she sends the--
ARNIE BURTON : She sends out
her Minions to check it out.
MARIO CORREA: Tell,
then, how was the hair?
ARNIE BURTON : Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So how do you
find-- Mario especially,
I guess-- how do you
find the balance?
Because there's so much
seriousness and realist
to the dialogue.
We had a tender moment
watching Anthony Weiner
admit wrongdoing.
But how do you find the
balance between the comedy
and the seriousness
to make it flow?
Was that difficult?
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
It is trial and effort, really.
And these guys, during
the rehearsal process,
really helped me with that.
Because there's just some
narrative that we just
have to put out there, even
if it's not a funny line.
But then, we, like
a joke, right?
So we played a lot with
moving things around, first
when I wrote it.
Then, when these
guys rehearsed it,
and they offered a lot of
suggestions during the process.
It really is a little
bit of trial and error.
And then, every
night is different.
Some nights, people laugh
at this versus that.
Luckily, they're
always laughing.
But what they laugh at tends
to vary night by night.
MARK DOUGLAS: Question.
AUDIENCE: So it's a question
about your research.
I noticed that all
of the politicians,
saying these funny
things, all are men.
So when you were
doing your research,
did you ever find any instances
of female politicians getting
stuck in these scandals?
Or does that just not happen?
MARIO CORREA: Not really.
I mean, first of
all, I should say
that-- I have said in
other interviews-- Google
is my collaborator on this play.
Because that's how
I found everything.
Literally, it's all I did was
fall into internet wormholes.
MARK DOUGLAS: You're welcome.
MARIO CORREA: More
and more Googling.
Mark Sanford plus
sex plus whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: But
there have been
a couple of women
politicians who've
been accused under the radar
of having been involved
in scandals, including the
current governor of South
Carolina, a woman.
But nothing that's actually
gotten out in the open
and been verified.
So it's basically men.
Men are the ones who are
doing it, by and large.
SEAN DUGAN: It's also there's
a larger societal thing.
I mean, what happens
when a woman teacher
sleeps with a male student.
There's a collective,
kind of "right on, boy".
Because we treat men
and women differently
in terms of sexuality.
And plus, you could
also say that women
are just smarter than men.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: There's also, I
guess, a little bit of history.
Because Barbara Walters did have
an affair that's been public,
right?
So she had the affair with
former Massachusetts Senator
Edward Brooke.
So Barbara, right?
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: If you could give
any advice to these Senators
on how to make things better--
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, my God.
No pressure there.
Well, I don't know.
Just to address this.
This is they're
so-- well, whatever.
I could use one of your
Barbara Walters things.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: Do Barbara while
it's not [INTERPOSING VOICES].
No, OK.
The very last line
of the show is
after all these
guys are going on
and on about,
"Here's why did it.
And I'm sorry. [BLAH BLAHS]
Then, they all leave the stage.
And then, Barbara Walters
just peeks to the audience.
And she's like, "I had an
affair with Edward Brooke,
the first African-American
elected to the US Senate
since Reconstruction.
The blackest man
I've ever been with."
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: That's
in her book, apparently.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: Apparently.
RACHEL DRATCH: Apparently that's
a direct quote from her book.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, that was
real [INTERPOSING VOICES]
from her book?
Oh, geez.
NATE SMITH: The
question should be,
you're up here listening to
four actors talk about politics,
man.
It should just be
like, do funny things.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: You think,
does Anthony Weiner
say "cack" like that really?
NATE SMITH: That was
actually the directors.
ARNIE BURTON : Nyoh, cack.
NATE SMITH: A specific
note from the directors.
ALAN SEALES: Actually makes
it a little less dirty.
[?
NATE SMITH: To say it c a k. ?]
MARK DOUGLAS: Well,
you know what's funny.
It seems like what happens
with a lot of these guys,
especially in the case
of Anthony Weiner,
I think a lot of
these guys are nerds.
So it's like they get famous.
And then, just the way
he tries to talk dirty,
he's not good at it.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: Yeah.
He's not.
I think that's two things.
One, I think it's like he's
[? skewing ?] what he really
wants to say sometimes.
And then, other times he's
just kind of a dork about it.
I've done some sexting.
And let me tell you something.
It's better to be direct.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM GALANTICH: If you take any
one thing away from this Talk,
be sure it's that.
AUDIENCE: ALAN SEALES:
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a wish list
for politicians you'd like
to see in scandals so you
can make fun of them?
[LAUGHTER]
[? TOM GALANTICH: Oh. ?]
MARIO CORREA: Wow.
Oh, to me?
Or anyone up here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, anyone.
MARIO CORREA: God, who would I
love to see in a sex scandal?
ALAN SEALES: I think Palin.
MARIO CORREA: I mean,
they're all in them already.
It's hard to think of one.
[? ARNIE BURTON : I'd ?]
like to see Boehner.
MARIO CORREA: You'd like to
see Boehner in a sex scandal?
BILLY ZAVELSON: Of course.
And McConnell.
I mean, God forbid
we see him in one.
But of course.
[? ARNIE BURTON : I think ?]
Palin would be good too.
Because she'd
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARIO CORREA: Yeah.
BILLY ZAVELSON:
INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARIO CORREA: Palin
Parade, actually.
That'd be a great
one-woman show, for sure.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: With
her little bob
sled there and the
whole thing, yeah.
[?
TOM GALANTICH:
[INTERPOSING VOICES] ?]
MARIO CORREA: Ready to stage it?
Yeah?
It'll happen.
BILLY ZAVELSON: You betcha.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: So bad.
So this is, obviously,
very scripted and very
well-organized. .
And the dialogue is
stacked together.
But did anybody, I
mean, just watching
you guys run through the
run-through this morning,
you're still, the cues
are very hard to remember,
and the the pickups.
And especially--
SEAN DUGAN: Excuse me,
but we nailed that.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Oh, the
performance was spot on.
MARK DOUGLAS: You make
it look really difficult.
[LAUGHTER]
NATE SMITH: We did a
press event last week.
And it involved a lot of
like, "Uh ay, what's my line?
Uh."
There are times when
it's really hard to do.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
I guess if you really
don't want to end up
improvising at all.
Because then, you're killing
the integrity of the--
[? MARIO CORREA: You ?] can't.
You can't.
ALAN SEALES: Has that
happened where during a show
you've just forgotten
lines and--?
SEAN DUGAN: Well, after our
days-long rehearsal process,
the rigorous 10 days we had,
there were a lot of times,
in the first few shows where--
RACHEL DRATCH: Like
the part in Weiner,
when I kept having to switch.
There was this big chunk where
I kept forgetting the lines.
Just not in the show, but
when we were rehearsing.
And I'd just be like, "Um,
about to fuck my friend?"
Because it was--
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA: That
was fallback always.
RACHEL DRATCH: It was
usually a pretty good chance
that's what the
person was saying.
So I was like, "Um,
can I bang friend now?"
NATE SMITH: Yeah, so it would
be just Plan B for the scene.
It was just like, oh, yeah.
We just skip those two pages.
MARIO CORREA: That's true.
If you guys curse and
say like, oh, fuck,
we just assume
it's the audience,
that that's part of the lines.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's
a pretty nice friend
that's just always on standby.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: It's hard
enough to remember
what's already in the script.
So it's always changing
due to the news, right?
But how do you rewrite
that and do the put-ins?
MARIO CORREA: Well,
these scandals
have had some things happen
in the last couple of weeks.
And we make small changes
to keep up with them.
But it's true.
When we were doing the
preview process, for example,
we were getting all this new
stuff from Sanford, and even
from some other scandals.
So we'd pick one a day.
Like, today, we're going
to do the new Sanford.
Tomorrow, we do the
new Larry Craig.
Because it's amazing
what these guys can
do in terms of
learning and adapting.
But I think we were
pushing them to the limit.
RACHEL DRATCH: Well, also
for this show, It was cool.
Because, with
Sanford, you imagine,
well, he did cheat on his wife.
But if that was his soul
mate, they're meant to be.
So, OK.
And then, during the
last part of rehearsal,
you find out that he broke it
off with the Argentinian woman.
And you're like, OK.
So he's just as much of a dirty
dog as all these other guys.
And so that's what
we added back in.
We added that into the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, I
remember feeling like,
when that happened,
I was like, well,
this guy really does seem
like he's in love. [CHUCKLES]
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: It seemed
like the most pure one.
But--
RACHEL DRATCH: Right.
ARNIE BURTON : And that
he didn't tell her--
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, well.
ARNIE BURTON : --in person.
He did it over Facebook.
SEAN DUGAN: On Facebook.
ARNIE BURTON : That's how
she found out, over Facebook.
RACHEL DRATCH:
And he thought she
understood they
were breaking up.
But then, she didn't.
And so then, she saw it on his
Facebook post or something.
[CHUCKLING]
MARIO CORREA: Always
check Facebook, I guess,
is the way I see it.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
MARK DOUGLAS: Do you
think they don't--
TOM GALANTICH: We're
back to my point.
MARK DOUGLAS: --understand
how technology works?
Is that some of that?
What it is?
TOM GALANTICH: Well, that's
what I was saying before.
MARK DOUGLAS: They
just think it's
a private message between
them or something?
ARNIE BURTON : That's right.
Because Bob Kerrey
came to see the show.
And we got to meet
him afterwards.
And he just gave us a
one-word description
for each of these guys.
Because he knows them all.
And he said Sanford
is just an idiot.
That's what he said about him.
[LAUGHTER]
MARIO CORREA:
Kerrey, for those who
don't remember, he was a
Senator, from Nebraska,
who ran for president in '92.
And he came, and saw
the show, and said,
"Oh, and thank you for
keeping me out of it."
And I said to him, "You
kept yourself out of it."
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, so we're
running short on time here.
We take one more question.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thank you so much for coming.
I just had a question about,
I guess, the creative process.
Do you think that having
the lines predetermined,
not being able to
improvise at all,
constrained your creative
process in any way,
either writing the show
or acting in the show?
Definitely in sketch, you
probably improvise a whole lot.
So I'm just wondering how it
was different for you guys
performing in this
versus something
where you have a
little more freedom.
RACHEL DRATCH: Well,
because this was a play.
I mean, so the good thing
is there was give and take.
If you had an idea like, maybe,
let's switch these lines around
or, I mean, basically
we kept the lines
as is to keep with that
thing that this is all really
what they said.
But if you saw an
angle on something,
then you could approach
Mario or Dan, the director,
with an idea.
But, for the most part, there's
no real in improv in it.
I mean, I guess, well, for
example, here's a good example.
Arnie, in his Gloria Allred,
or Arnie does this character,
is a very straight line.
It's just this guy saying,
"The South Carolina--"
What's your line there?
[? SEAN DUGAN: South ?]
Carolina [INTERPOSING VOICES]
ARNIE BURTON : (AMERICAN
SOUTHERN ACCENT) The General
Assembly does hearby
censor Marshall Sanford Jr.
for dereliction of his duties.
RACHEL DRATCH: Yeah, so it's
just this very straight thing
of Mark Sanford being censored.
But he comes out and does
this whole big, almost
like a Foghorn
Leghorn character.
And the audience
goes nuts for it.
He applies kind of a sketch
vibe to a very straight line.
So that's kind of how a game
is sketchy in this sense.
But no verbal improv.
ARNIE BURTON : It
is interesting.
Because, sometimes,
during a rehearsal process
and you work with a
playwright, and you can work.
And he can change and rewrite
things with the actor in mind.
And you combine
and make it happen.
But in this, the trick
was exactly like you said,
it's very predetermined.
And there's no futzing
with the lines.
You have to keep the
integrity of what they said.
So we have to come at
it at a different way.
Like what can we bring?
What can we do with the
lines to make them pop,
or to make the joke pop, or
bring a character to the lines?
Because there's
nothing we can do.
Those are set in stone.
SEAN DUGAN: And
there's so much of it
that's really rapid-fire
timing that we're all
speaking together, sharing
lines, or talking right
after the other.
That was probably
the trickiest part
of the early part of the
process and early performances
where if you drop something,
you're just toast.
And that we had to just
keep doing it over and over,
and drill it, and just get it
so we could be more free to--
ARNIE BURTON : But it's
such a good group of people.
Because if we do drop
it, which we still do,
it's a play where you can
laugh and acknowledge it.
And you can catch
someone's eye and just
realize how ridiculous
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
Yeah.
NATE SMITH: Nobody knows
[INTERPOSING VOICES] like that.
ALAN SEALES: Well, it must be.
Sanford's like that.
MARK DOUGLAS:
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
be really tough
because he's talking,
he's pulling things
out of this butt.
He's just digging--
TOM GALANTICH: Or Mario's,
Mario's butt, yeah.
No, honestly, I approached
it like any play,
like any play or show.
MARK DOUGLAS: Funny
man, funny man.
TOM GALANTICH: Yeah.
I mean, Mario gave
us the blueprint.
He gave us the
step-by-step screw
goes here, nail goes here,
stud goes there, literally.
And it's our job, as actors,
to then take that and make
the most of it, and
make what we can of it.
And that was the
improvisation aspect to it.
You take what you're given
and make the most of it.
And so it's a real collaboration
between writer, and director,
and cast.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well,
I think that's it.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: The
show is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK DOUGLAS: You guys
really should go see it.
ALAN SEALES: Visit them down
at the Lynn Redgrave Theater.
Visit them online,
tailspinshow.com, Instagram,
and Twitter-- @TailSpinShow.
Yeah, I think that, should
we get a current state
of the world from Debbie Downer?
RACHEL DRATCH: Oh, God.
No, no.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: Are
you kidding me?
MARK DOUGLAS: What would Debbie
Downer have to say about Ebola?
RACHEL DRATCH: No.
What are you doing to me?
TOM GALANTICH: They can't
see how they're doing to you.
RACHEL DRATCH: We're
about to wrap it up.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL DRATCH: I'm
like, we're done here.
MARK DOUGLAS: I know.
ALAN SE-ALES: All right.
No, 40 seconds overtime.
RACHEL DRATCH: [SOBS]
SEAN DUGAN: We're just getting
our Google glasses out.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
Give a big round of
applause. [APPLAUSE]
BILLY ZAVELSON:
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]